bonjour merci de nous rejoindre ce matin
sur l'antenne de public sénat pour
suivre une séance qui s'est déroulée en
fait il hier en fin d'après midi
ici à la haye au sénat autour du projet
de loi fatca fatca c'est foreign account
tax act
c'est un projet de loi français qui vise
à mettre en oeuvre et bien un nouvel
article du code fiscal américain
c'est article du code fiscal américain
de ban demande aux banques de signaler
tous renseignements concernant les
comptes détenus par des citoyens
américains qui vivent ta à l'étranger
l'objectif est bien c'est de rendre plus
transparent ses déclarations de
patrimoine mais aussi de lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale
au niveau mondial il n'y a pas eu de
levée particulière de boucliers 1 contre
ce projet de loi fatca en france
pourtant il s'agit d'une extra
territorialité du droit américain
ce texte place en fait quand même eh
bien les établissements financiers sous
la domination du droit fiscal américain
alors pour bien comprendre tout autour
de ce projet de loi fatca je vous
propose de vous rendre dans l'hémicycle
du sénat très bonne séance à tous à
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi autorisant l'approbation
de l'accord entre le gouvernement de la
république française et le gouvernement
des états unis d'amérique en vue
d'améliorer le respect des obligations
fiscales à l'échelle internationale et
de mettre en oeuvre la loi relative au
respect des obligations fiscales
concernant les comptes étrangers dite
loi fatca dans la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur christian équerre
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget
la présidente monsieur le président
madame la rapporteure mais là messieurs
les sénateurs
l'accord qui est soumis à votre
ratification est particulièrement
novateur puisqu'il s'agit du premier
texte signé par la france avec un autre
état en vue de permettre la mise en
oeuvre d'un échange automatique
d'informations à des fins fiscales
sur un très large éventail de données
bancaires
cet accord est d'abord le fruit des
négociations menées par la france et ses
partenaires européens en vue de
promouvoir un échange automatique sur
une base bilatérale est réciproque avec
les états unis
à l'origine la loi fatca foreign account
tax compliance act du 18 mars 2010 est
une décision du congrès américain qui
impose à toutes les banques étrangères
l'obligation de transmettre aux états
unis des informations sur les comptes
des citoyens américains
quelle que soit la localisation de ces
comptes
cette obligation est sanctionné en cas
de non-respect par une retenue à la
source de 30 % appliquée aux revenus
financiers versés depuis les etats unis
vers les comptes tenus par
l'établissement dès 2010
les institutions financières ont donc
sollicité l'aide du gouvernement
français demandant qu'il intervienne
auprès des autorités américaines
c'est pourquoi la france a été à
l'origine d'une démarche alternative
avec quatre de ses partenaires
l'allemagne l'espagne l'italie et le
royaume uni appelez le groupe des 5 ou
g5
il en est résulté l'adoption d'un modèle
intergouvernementale permettant
d'obtenir les avantages suivants
tout d'abord les échanges d'informations
se feront d'administration
administration ce qui offre des gares
si en termes de confidentialité ainsi
que des formats ou des procédures des
procédures des changes calquer sur les
formats existants
ensuite la signature d'un accord
bilatéral permet de réputés que
l'ensemble des institutions financières
du pays signataires se conforment à
fatca et sont dispensés de la retenue à
la source
si l'accord est respecté enfin les états
européens ont pu négocier avec les états
unis tant sur les modalités pratiques
que sur le champ des établissements
concernés la france et ses partenaires
ont enfin obtenu que par ce modèle
d'accord les états unis acceptent
d'entrer dans une démarche de
réciprocité de sorte qu'ils fourniront
également des informations à notre
administration fiscale sur des comptes
bancaires détenus aux états unis
c'est donc ce modèle proposé par la
france et depuis repris par la très
grande majorité des états avec lesquels
les etats-unis négocient la maison la
mise en loge de fatca qui a servi de
cadre de référence à l'accord franco
américain signé en novembre dernier est
aujourd'hui soumis à votre approbation
concrètement l'accord entre la france et
les états unis 6 le cadre de l'échangé
automatique d'informations et précise
l'ensemble des procédures que les deux
états devront mettre en oeuvre pour y
satisfaire ainsi les autorités
françaises collecteront des informations
sur les citoyens et résidents des
états-unis identification solde les
comptes valeur de rachat des contrats
d'assurance-vie revenus financiers
en adoptant il ya un an les dispositions
depuis codifié à l'article 1649 à c du
code général des impôts
le parlement a par ailleurs adapter
notre droit interne pour créer
l'obligation nécessaire et la capacité
de l'administration française à
collecter les informations
la première transmission est fixée au 30
septembre 2015
elle sera en
it annuel en réponse à la demande de la
france les états unis ont accepté un
principe général de réciprocité et sa
mise en oeuvre dans les domaines très
majoritaire ou leur législation le
permet de plus les etats unis se sont
expressément engagées à promouvoir des
réformes pour parvenir à une réciprocité
complète les états unis devront ainsi
nous transmettre dès 2015 le numéro de
compte ainsi que le montant des intérêts
dividendes et autres revenus versés aux
crédité sur ce compte pour des résidents
français et lyon ayant pardon un compte
dans un établissement américain pour les
autres informations l'identification des
comptes permettra ensuite à la france de
demander des informations au cas par cas
dans le cadre de la convention fiscale
bilatérale existante
l'accord confère enfin la france le
droit de disposer de toute clause plus
favorable signé par les états unis dans
un accord de nature identique
toutefois pour l'instant il n'en existe
pas de plus favorable mais cet accord se
situe aussi dans un cadre plus large et
prometteur grâce aux efforts menés par
la france et ses partenaires au g20 nous
espérons pouvoir bientôt instituer un
système multilatéral d'échangé
automatique copié sur fait qu'à qui
représente une chance historique de
faire enfin reculer le secret bancaire
fatca a permis de développer l'échangé
automatique au niveau international en
impliquant de nombreux états dont des
centres financiers qui sont désormais
priver d'arguments pour ne pas le mettre
en oeuvre
dans une lettre commune du 9 avril 2013
envoyée la commission européenne la
france l'allemagne l'espagne l'italie et
le royaume uni ont signifié leur volonté
de développer un projet pilote
multilatérale
reposant sur un format des changes
inspiré de celui prévu dans le cadre
accor fait qu'à américain parallèlement
ces cinq états ont convaincu le g20 lors
du sommet de saint pétersbourg de
septembre 2013 de confier à l' ocde la
réalisation d'un standard mondial qui
aurait vocation de s'appliquer aussi
bien en europe que dans le reste du
monde
le standard unique est désormais adopté
par l' ocde et il sera présenté au
prochain g20 en septembre en australie
il reprend lui aussi le chant et les
procédures de fait qu'à la france et ses
partenaires ont parallèlement rassembler
une masse critique de 45 états et
territoires partenaires qui s'engagent à
mettre en oeuvre le standard le plus tôt
possible entre 2015 et 2017
ils signeront des accords d'échangé
automatique d'informations entre eux et
avec les 40 autres partenaires du projet
en octobre prochain
enfin l'initiative du g5 a été soutenue
par le conseil européen pour un
calendrier de mise en oeuvre rapide de
l' échange automatique d'informations au
sein de l'union européenne
grâce à la révision de la directive
relative à la coopération administrative
dans le domaine fiscal qui permettra
d'intégrer le standard des changes de l'
ocde dans la législation communautaire
ce mouvement que la france soutient
depuis longtemps et par tous les moyens
est désormais en marche et il est
irrémédiable comme en témoigne le
ralliement de plusieurs centres
financiers importants tels progrès au
profit de tous était encore impensable
il ya encore deux ou trois ans fatca ya
contribué
reconnaissons le mais aussi et peut-être
surtout ce que nous européens sommes
parvenus à faire de fait qu'à et la
france ya joué un rôle important
c'est dans ce contexte particulier qui
vous êtes aujourd'hui deux groupes qui
vous est aujourd'hui proposé de rats
qui fier l'accord conclu entre la france
et les états unis
il marque un premier jalon important
dans la lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale dans la lutte contre
l'opacité et le secret bancaire
autant d'objectifs qui nous rassemble je
le sais car vos travaux en témoigne et
sans distinction partisane au sein de
cet hémicycle
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à mme à l'ats michel andré rapporteur de
la commission des finances madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui le projet de loi autorisant
l'approbation de l'accord signé le 14
novembre 2013 entre la france et les
etats unis en vue d'appliquer la loi
fatca aussi je vais y aller de ma
traduction foreign account tax
compliance act la commission des
finances du sénat s'est penché sur le
sujet à plusieurs reprises et notamment
lors des auditions conjointe du 3
juillet 2013 et du 12 février 2014
notre collègue nicole bricq en avait
déjà abordé les principaux enjeux dès
l'année 2011
alors que la mode était aux accords
rubik c'est ultime tentative de sauver
le secret bancaire dont on ne parle même
plus aujourd'hui la loi fatca adoptée
par les états unis en 2010 ne
s'embarrasse pas des mêmes précautions
elle oblige tout simplement les banques
et établissements financiers du monde
entier à transmettre aux états unis
toutes les informations dont il dispose
sur les contribuables américains
personnes physiques et entités sous
peine d'une retenue à la source
dissuasive de 30 % des flux concernées
personne ne l'ignorent ici la loi fatca
a été l'élément déclencheur de progrès
considérables dans la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale internationale
le sillage de l'initiative américaine
l'union européenne et l'osce et de ce
fonds lancé dans l'élaboration de
standards d'échangé automatique
d'informations
bien plus efficace que l'actuel échanges
à la demande qui est plus tôt
un échange à la carte quand il dépend de
la bonne volonté des partenaires avec
l'échangé automatique il ne sera plus
possible de s'abriter derrière une
demande mal formulés ou un quelconque
vice de procédure pour ne pas révéler
l'identité des contribuables indélicats
or il faut être très clair l'échangé
automatique d'informations autre nom de
la transparence fiscale que réclame
depuis longtemps la société civile
n'aurait jamais vu le jour sans la loi
fatca cette filiation est d'ailleurs
assumé le standard l' ocde qui sera
présenté au g20 à l'automne prochain
s'inspire directement de fait car il en
va de même pour la directive européenne
sur la coopération administrative de
2011 dont la révision est en cours
l'extension de l'échangé automatique aux
produits couverts par la directive
épargne de 2003 a quant à elle elle fait
l'objet d'un accord le 24 mars dernier
suite à la levée du veto du luxembourg
et de l'autriche
eux aussi pousser au changement par
l'aiguillon de la loi fatca certes la
méthode employée par les états unis est
un peu cavalière c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire telle que votée en 2010 la
loi fatca était un dispositif
unilatérale et extraterritoriale qui ne
laissait tout simplement aucun choix aux
autres pays et à leurs établissements
financiers quelle grande banque en effet
pourrait se permettre de se voir fermer
l'accès au marché américain et de loin
le plus grand du monde
mais l'objet de l'accord que nous
examinons aujourd'hui et très
précisément de transformer un dispositif
unilatérale en accord bilatéral négocié
entre états souverains réciproque est
assorti de multiples garanties
suite à l'action de la france et à ses
principaux partenaires européens la loi
fatca a véritablement changé de nature
l'accord signé par la france permet une
mise en oeuvre de fait cas de manière
centralisée les données transiteront par
l'administration fiscale française
parader gfip au lieu d'être transmises
directement par les banques
ceci diminue considérablement les
surcoûts financiers les complications
techniques et les incertitudes
juridiques d'impliquer le dispositif
original de plus les entités et produits
soumis à l'échangé automatique reçoivent
une définition compatible avec le droit
français une clause de la nation la plus
favorisée permet à la france
et à ces banques de bénéficier de toute
stipulation plus favorable que les états
unis accorderait à un autre pays
de plus la france pourra toujours
invoquer les dispositions du code fiscal
américain si celles-ci lui sont plus
favorables que les termes de l'accord en
bref l'accord fatca pourrait évoluer
dans un sens plus favorable à la france
mais jamais dans un sens moins favorable
il est vrai toutefois qu'une incertitude
importante demeure la question de la
réciprocité de l'accord et par
conséquent de sa compatibilité avec le
standard international qui lui est
parfaitement réciproque en effet des
élus républicains du congrès blanc
actuellement la transmission du solde
des comptes bancaires dans le cadre du
dispositif
même si toutes les autres informations
identité du contribuable revenus vers
ces banques concernées etc pourront être
fournis par les états unis
il ne faut pas surestimer cependant les
conséquences de ce blocage dans la
mesure où la france peut toujours
sollicité les informations manquantes
via les changes à la demande qui
fonctionne très bien entre les deux pays
mais la réciprocité est aussi une
question de principe à laquelle nous
devons rester très attachée
alors que l'union européenne et le cd de
mettre chaque pays sur un pied d'égalité
il ne serait pas acceptable que les
états unis puisse déroger à cette règle
les etats unis sont formellement engagés
à mettre en oeuvre une réciprocité
complète dès que leur droit interne leur
permettra cela figure en toutes lettres
à l'article 6 de l'accord le ministre
pourra certainement nous rendre compte
en séance des avancées en la matière et
nous en reparlerons si nécessaire à
l'occasion du projet de loi de finances
pour 2015 pour sa part la france doit
continuer à soutenir l'adoption d'un
standard mondial unique réciproque et
harmonisée qui demeure la seule réponse
viable à long terme à la menace que
l'évasion fiscale fait peser sur notre
souveraineté ces questions en suspens ne
doivent pas occulter le chemin parcouru
qui est considérable nous partions d'un
dispositif imposé et nous avons
aujourd'hui un accord négocié largement
réciproque est assorti de multiples
garanties comme toute négociation
internationale s'agit d'un rapport de
force
quand on se bat il est possible de faire
changer les choses l'année dernière par
exemple commissaire barnier avait obtenu
après d'âpres négociations que les
régulation américaines et européennes en
matière de produits
river soit considérée comme strictement
équivalente la loi fatca témoigne d'une
véritable action menée par les états
unis pour combattre les abus du système
financier il serait faux de n'y voir que
la manifestation d'une sévérité
sélective qui ne s'appliquerait qu'aux
banques étrangères il en va d'ailleurs
de même pour les amendes infligées aux
banques faut-il rappeler que jp morgan a
dû payer 13 milliards de dollars l'année
dernière que citigroup a accepté de
verser 7 milliards de dollars 14 juillet
dernier et la justice américaine réclame
près de 17 milliards de dollars à bank
of america
un record absolu justifié par son rôle
dans la crise des subprimes
enfin pour en revenir au sujet il faut
reconnaître à l'initiative américaine le
mérite d'avoir provoqué un véritable
sursaut internationale en faveur de
l'échangé automatique qui porte déjà ses
premiers fruits la loi fatca n'est pas
pour rien dans le changement d'attitude
des banques suisses qui encouragent
aujourd'hui leurs clients à régulariser
leur situation
il s'agit d'un phénomène réel dont les
excellents résultats du service de
traitement des déclarations
rectificatives mis en place en juin 2013
viennent attester
et hier encore ici même monsieur le
ministre vous nous confirmer que
l'objectif de 1,85 milliard d'euros de
recettes pourrait être dépassé la
signature de l'accord fac fatca un
accord véritablement équilibré permettra
de maintenir une saine pression pour que
les engagements pris ne demeurent pas de
vains mots
la défense de la souveraineté fiscale de
la france et de ses partenaires
européens exigent de ne pas laisser
passer cette chance je vous recommande
pour toutes ces raisons d'adopter sans
modification le pro le présent projet de
loi de ratification et je vous
remercions merci madame la rapporteure
la parole est à monsieur philippe marini
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
et le sénat et la première assemblée
saisi du projet de loi de ratification
de l'accord avec les etats-unis pour
mettre en oeuvre la loi américaine dite
fatca et que mes prédécesseurs à cette
tribune on remarquablement explicite et
avec l'accent approprié et le sujet est
important et je remercie le gouvernement
d'avoir de son propre mouvement demandé
que ce texte soit discutée selon la
procédure normale et non selon la
procédure simplifiée prévue pour les
accords internationaux
je ne vais pas tout à fait tirer les
mêmes conclusions que michel andré de
nos trois années de travail en
commission sur le dispositif fatca trois
années parce qu'en 2011
notre collègue nicole bricq qui était à
l'époque rapporteur général nous avait
invités à y voir au delà d'une
manifestation de ligny latéral isme
américain une opportunité pour la
révision de la directive européenne sur
les poules l'analyse que présentait
alors la rapporteur général de la
commission des finances du sénat est
devenu depuis lors le discours officiels
des gouvernements européens et de l'
ocde fatca ne serait plus une décision
unilatérale d'un pays puissant qui
montre ainsi l'idée qu'il a de son
importance et je cite entre guillemets
ce propos qui reprend les termes qui
avait été employé par la ministre
valérie pécresse devant notre commission
des finances en janvier 2012 donc fatca
ne serai plus là mais serait une
chance pour la transparence fiscale et
la fin du secret bancaire
le déclencheur d'un mouvement mondial en
faveur de l' échange automatique
d'informations on ne peut pas nier qu'il
se passe quelque chose en europe sur ce
terrain de l'échangé d'informations en
matière fiscale mais je suis en droit me
semble-t-il de m'interroger
l'europe est-elle à l'avant garde d'un
mouvement mondial ou bien encore une
fois le trop bons élèves qui risquent
quelques désillusions des pays comme la
chine ou singapour n'ont pas encore
dépassé le stade des engagements de
principe à l'égard de fatca et hong kong
est en train de négocier comme la suisse
au demeurant un modèle d'accord qui
préserve largement le secret bancaire
est ce qu'il y aurait s mes chers
collègues parce qu'il y aurait moins
d'américains susceptible de détenir dans
ce pays des comptes bancaires ou bien
parce que les états unis ont plus de mal
à y faire appliquer leurs règles
extraterritoriale au fond n'est-ce pas
de cela qu'il s'agit d'un nouvel exemple
de l'impérialisme juridique de ce que
j'appellerais volontiers l'impérialisme
juridiques des états unis alors j'étais
je suis heureux de susciter l'intérêt de
au sein de notre avait par ses propos
peut-être un peu dissonante par rapport
à ce que l'on a entendu jusqu'ici
j'étais son mois d'avril
d'ailleurs avec michel andré et quelques
collègues de la commission des finances
du bureau de la commission en iran nous
avons observé
que si les états unis sont très dures on
l'a bien vu avec les banques qui
compense ce temps dollars des
transactions avec l'iran
ils ne sont aucunement gêné par la
présence dans ce pays de nombre de leurs
entreprises
boeing pour des fournitures de matériels
aéronautiques ou coca cola dans le cadre
d'accords de licence l'année dernière
c'était tôt et on pourrait citer bien
d'autres exemples en effet l'année
dernière c'était aux états unis au
demeurant que le bureau de notre
commission s'était rendu qui avions nous
observer que les régulateurs américains
veulent appliquer aux banques étrangères
notamment européennes des règles de
solvabilité plus dure à leurs banques
domestiques que la réserve fédérale n'a
pas peur de contrôler non seulement les
filiales américaines mais aussi le
niveau de capital des maisons mères par
exemple européenne
parfois il est arrivé que dans ce
dialogue difficile avec nos amis
américains
la raison l'emportent et en matière de
réglementation des dérivés
il a fallu une coalition mondiale
l'europe le brésil l'afrique du sud le
japon la russie pour persuader la cftc
américaine de renoncer à son projet de
ne plus appliquer le principe de
reconnaissance mutuelle entre les
superviseurs alors avec fatca mes chers
collègues à cette heure tardive
sommes nous dans un cas de soumission
pure et simple aux exigences américaines
ou bien sommes-nous pas revenue
à atteindre un accord équilibré certes
les apparences sont préservés puisque un
dispositif initial qui s'appliquait
directement aux banques non américaines
où qu'elles soient dans le monde est
devenu un régime d'accord entraîneur
michel andré nous a dit que le
dispositif est presque totalement
réciproque puisque presque tous tient
dans le presque
et puisque nous pourrons obtenir des
états unis toutes les informations à
l'exception du solde des comptes
bancaires qui demeurent soumis à une
procédure fastidieuse et limité à
quelques dizaines de cas chaque année
pourtant j'imagine que l'administration
fiscale française ne serait pas
mécontente de disposer de ces soldes
notamment pour s'assurer que tous les
avoirs détenus aux états unis sont bien
en règle au titre des différents impôts
et en particulier des impôts sur le
patrimoine
on nous dit aussi que le gouvernement
américain s'est engagé à une réciprocité
totale dès que son droit interne le
permettraient mais cela fait deux fois
que le président obama présente au
congrès des dispositions en ce sens et
qu'elles ne sont pas adoptées c'est le
jeu de la séparation des pouvoirs aux
états unis alors y at il une véritable
intention de passer à l'acte une
capacité à le faire
au-delà de ces quelques démonstrations
de bonne volonté et qui ne sont pas
forcément très engageante
aujourd'hui de toute façon que l'arrêt
que la réciprocité soit juridiquement
totale ou partielle les etats-unis
ont-ils la capacité matérielle de
fournir les informations en question
j'ai un souvenir lorsque nous étions aux
états unis l'année dernière on nous a
expliqué que la collecte des
informations seraient beaucoup
plus difficile aux états unis qu'en
europe ceci en raison des structures du
système bancaire le système bancaire
américain est beaucoup moins concentrés
que les systèmes bancaires de nos
nations européennes
aux états unis il faut recueillir
l'information dans des centaines de
petites banques au prix de coûts sans
doute bien supérieur aux 200 à 300
millions d'euros dépensés depuis 2011
pour les banques françaises et sans
oublier que ces petites banques dans les
états sont soumises chacune à un
mécanisme de régulation d'état qui peut
présenter de fortes spécificités donc
les états unis j'en ai la conviction
n'appliqueront pas vraiment ou
n'appliqueront sans doute qu'un jour
relativement éloigné les règles affirmé
parfaite cas et il n'appliqueront pas
davantage le standard de l' ocde
en d'autres termes et si la loi
américaine fatca est à l'origine d'un
grand mouvement de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale des particuliers dans
le monde
est ce que le pays qu'il a voté il
participera pleinement
je me pose cette question avec en tête
quelques exemples historiques de grandes
initiatives américaines suivies dans
l'ensemble du monde mais en définitive
assez peu aux états unis eux mêmes
la question qui se pose désormais est
celle de la manière dont ce grand pays
s'impliquera dans l'autre grande
chantier dans l'autre grand chantier
j'en terminerai par là de fiscalité
internationale d'aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire celui de la lutte contre l'
optimisation fiscale des grandes
entreprises multinationales notamment
américaines notamment n'est pas
seulement dans le domaine de l'économie
du numérique
l' ocde vous le savez a lancé un
chantier prometteur auquel nous sommes
beaucoup intéressés et c'est le projet
sur l'érosion des bases et le transfert
des profits que l'on appelle bates
l'objectif est que les états
dont les consommateurs alimente le
chiffre d'affaires des grandes
multinationales perçoivent un retour des
recettes fiscales qui permettent de
financer les systèmes sociaux grâce
auxquels ses consommateurs disposent de
pouvoir d'achat et peuvent acquérir les
biens et services commercialisés par ces
multinationales sur le sol des états
européens
là encore on peut être inquiet de
l'évolution de la position américaine je
voudrais alerté le sénat et à ce sujet
il ya un peu plus d'un an en irlande du
nord le g8 dont entier avait pris des
positions encourageantes sur le sujet
mais au printemps de cette année
les milieux économiques américains se
sont réveillés et ont entrepris un
travail de lobbying efficace qui a
débouché selon une dépêche afp du 4 juin
sur la prise de position suivante du
trésor américains l'administration obama
défendra auprès de l' ocde
le principe qu'une entreprise ne peut
être taxé dans un pays que si elle y est
je cite physiquement présentes
faut-il en déduire que la logique de du
projet betts est remise en cause
pouvons nous interroger sérieusement à
ce sujet serons nous encore berné deux
mots dans le cadre d'une concurrence
fiscale mondialisé et débridée le g8 de
brisbane des 15 et 16 novembre est en
préparation et nous apportera sans doute
quelques éléments de réponse à ces
questions
mes chers collègues certes nous n'avons
pas la puissance des états unis mais
nous avons encore le droit d'avoir
l'esprit critique et de dire un moment
donné ce que nous pensions alors pour ce
qui me concerne je respecte
pleinement la position qui va être
exprimé toute leur certainement de façon
excellente par mon groupe et par la voix
de francis delattre
il a été tellement convaincants en
réunion de la commission à mon égard qu
alors que j'envisageais de voter contre
eh bien je me bornerai à m'abstenir je
vous remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le président dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole et madame à la parole est à
madame anne marie escoffier pour le
groupe eads
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances madame le
rapporteur chers collègues pendant de
nombreuses années l'évasion fiscale a
été considérée si ce n'est comme une
fatalité du moins comme un problème tout
à fait secondaire
certes l'organisation de coopération et
de développement économiques avait tenté
d'attirer l'attention sur la concurrence
fiscale dommageable
depuis la fin des années 90 mais ce
n'est qu'après l'éclatement de la crise
financière mondiale en 2008 2009 et la
succession d'un certain nombre de
scandales qu'une véritable prise de
conscience est intervenu fléau pour nos
finances publiques atteinte choquant à
l'égalité devant l'impôt et à la justice
fiscale
les phénomènes d'évasion et
d'optimisation fiscale occupe depuis
lors le devant de la scène
internationale à l'issue du g20 de
londres de 2009 le cd a établi les
fameuses listes noires et grises des
états et territoires non coopératifs
conséquence de cette stigmatisation
répondant au principe du naming
ennjimi le nombre d'accord d'échangé de
renseignements en matière fiscale a été
multiplié par plus de 30 en l'espace de
quelques années pour autant et nous le
constatons aujourd'hui cette
multiplication des accords fiscaux
bilatéraux qui repose sur
échange à la demande n'a pas exactement
produit les effets escomptés
l'évasion fiscale demeure un phénomène
important et l'opacité de certains
paradis fiscaux se serait même renforcé
ces dernières années
cela s'explique notamment par le fait
que malgré la signature de convention
fiscale
certains pays ne transmettent pas les
renseignements demandés ainsi l'opacité
président bien souvent dans
l'indisponibilité des informations
avancées par les administrations
fiscales concernées certains territoires
joue également sur des divergences
d'interprétation pour bloquer les
échanges d'informations ainsi en août
2013 jersey les bermudes les îles
vierges britanniques ont été ré inscrire
sur la liste française des états et
territoires non coopératifs
suite aux difficultés rencontrées par
notre administration pour obtenir les
réponses demandées
ces territoires n'auront fait qu'un
retour express sur la liste puisque deux
d'entre eux en sont sortis quelques mois
plus tard le 17 janvier 2014 suite
apparemment à des progrès notables
cependant certains états n'ont tout
simplement pas la capacité normative et
administratives nécessaires au respect
de leurs engagements et ce problème
demeure même dans le cas d'un échange
automatique et non plus à la demande
en 2010 les états unis ont donc adopté
de manière unilatérale la loi fatca qui
a fait l'effet d'un véritable coup de
tonnerre et ça a été rappelé dans le
monde financier
l'accord entre la france et des états
unis que nous examinons ce soir est la
traduction de cette loi dans une logique
de réciprocité certains ont émis des
réserves face à la méthode
en effet tout à fait brutales utilisées
par les états unis
il est vrai que la ratification de
l'accord qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
peut s'apparenter à une sorte de vote
bloqué imposé par un pays tiers
d'ailleurs l'extraterritorialité de
droit américain
est un problème plus large qui ne
s'arrête pas au seul domaine financier
cela n'est guère satisfaisant mais
malgré ces réserves
et comme l'a démontré notre rapporteur
cet accord constitue pour diverses
raisons un véritable progrès ainsi par
rapport à la loi fatca unilatérale et
extra territoriales de 2010 avec à la
clé une sanction pour les banques d'une
retenue à la source de 30 % surtout
revenus d'origine américaine nous avons
aujourd'hui un accord bilatéral
équilibré qui offre un certain nombre de
garanties pour avancer vers une réelle
transparence fiscale dont la france
serait bien sûr bénéficiaires ainsi
l'accord prévoit une clause de la nation
la plus favorisée qui permettra à la
france de se prévaloir de toute clause
plus favorable que les états unis
pourraient conclure à l'avenir avec
d'autres états cet accord repose sur un
principe de réciprocité qui applique
l'administration américaine devra
transmettre à la france les mêmes
informations sur les revenus de
contribuables français qu'il s'agisse de
ménage ou d'entreprises la réciprocité
de cet accord sur les changes
automatique d'informations avec les
états unis représentent comme l'a
souligné michel andré un enjeu fiscale
réelle pour notre pays
cependant nous devons rester extrêmement
vigilant pour que l'entière
responsabilité de cet accord soit
garanti tout à l'heure on a utilisé à
deux reprises le mot presque presque
garanti actuellement le congrès
américain bloque en effet la
transmission des soldes de comptes
bancaires
si la ratification de cet accord fatca
constitue un grand pas en avant vers la
généralisation de l'échangé automatique
d'informations des difficultés
subsistent néanmoins dans sa mise en
oeuvre
la question du traitement d'informations
très important qui résulteront de
l'échangé automatique mérite d'être
posée tout l'enjeu
consistera maintenant pour les
administrations fiscales à utiliser
efficacement les données issues de ces
recoupements notre administration
monsieur le ministre
et c'est une vraie question at-elle
aujourd'hui les moyens humains
techniques et financiers pour répondre à
ces objectifs
en outre même si nous avançons vers un
standard mondial fondé sur les changes
automatique
ce que chacun et s'ils souhaitent la
faiblesse juridique de certains
territoires demeurera un obstacle à
l'échangé d'informations pertinentes que
cet échange soit automatique ou à la
demande
de plus alors que les choses avancent
relativement bien aux états unis en
europe
n'y at il pas un risque de transfert de
l'évasion fiscale et de l'opacité vers
d'autres territoires plus lointains
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
comme hong kong ou singapour enfin pour
instaurer une réelle transparence des
étapes complémentaires devront être
franchies il s'agit en particulier de
l'harmonisation fiscale à l'échelle
européenne en matière d'impôts sur les
sociétés avec le projet assiette commune
consolidée de l'impôt sur les sociétés
ou en abrégé à six qui demeure
malheureusement pour l'instant lettre
morte
il faut espérer que la possibilité de
mettre en place une coopération
renforcée deviendra une réalité pour que
la règle de l'unanimité qui prévaut pour
les décisions européennes sur les
questions fiscales cesse d'être une
barrière pour les pays qui veulent
avancer vers plus de transparence et
d'égalité
ces propositions figurent dans les
rapports des commissions d'enquêté
sénatoriale sur l'évasion des capitaux
de 2012 et 2013 dont il faut saluer le
travail fondateur il faudra aussi
s'assurer de l'avancée du projet bep s
de l' ocde qui vise à lutter contre
l'érosion de la base fiscale le
transfert des bénéfices parviendrons
nous c'est une question à redéfinir la
notion d'établissement stable sur
laquelle restent basés les règles
fiscales internationales pour
l'imposition des sociétés et qui ne
correspond plus aux réalités économiques
notamment celles de l'économie numérique
dont nous avons souvent débattu le
chemin à parcourir est encore long mais
la conclusion d'un accord tel que fatca
nous donne de bonnes raisons d'espérer
espérons qu'un fatca européen verra
rapidement le jour où plutôt qu'un
standard mondial unique comme celui
préparé par l' ocde se mettra en place
pour éviter la superposition de normes
différentes
une chose reste sûre sans
l'unilatéralisme de la loi fatca permis
par l'hégémonie américaine
nous ne discuterions probablement pas
aujourd'hui de l'échangé automatique
d'informations au niveau mondial nous en
serions encore probablement à
tergiverser sur les états inscrire ou à
désinscrire de nos listes de paradis
fiscaux dont l'efficacité tout de même
beaucoup plus limité par conséquent
monsieur le ministre madame le
rapporteur l'ensemble des membres de
notre groupe rdse votera cet accord
franco-américain qui constitue une
véritable avancée vers la transparence
fiscale mondiale
dans un souci de justice et d'équité
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur andré gattolin
pour le groupe écologiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux et
plus généralement contre les dérives qui
a permis la dérégulation financière est
un sujet qui importe par tout
particulièrement aux écologistes pour
les pays industrialisés comme le nôtre
ces dérives se traduit chaque année par
des milliards d'euros de manque à gagner
en termes de ressources fiscales pour
les pays disposant d'appareils étatique
moins fort que les nôtres elle entraîne
des pertes plus importantes encore dans
les conséquences pour les populations
les services publics les sociétés sont
démultipliés du fait de la faiblesse de
ses états vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que les grandes entreprises de notre
pays sont aussi souvent celles qui
paient au moins proportionnellement le
moins d'impôts c'est le cas également
ailleurs par exemple aux états unis où
les rapports ont par le passé montré que
certaines compagnies était même parvenu
à réduire leurs contributions fiscales à
néant
je pense notamment à une autre étude
aujourd'hui fameuses du government
accountability office américain
commandé en 2008 par deux sénateurs
démocrates
cette étude avait révélé qu'un quart des
entreprises américaines bénéficiant de
plus de 250 milliards d'actifs ou de
plus de cinquante 250 millions de
dollars d'actifs ou de plus de 50
millions de dollars de recette n'avait
tout simplement pas payer un solde
dollars d'impôts entre 1998 et 2005 et
les mêmes procédés se retrouve du côté
des individus fortunés
usant comme ces entreprises de toutes
les possibilités légales mais même
parfois moins légale et de toutes les
failles de notre système financier pour
diminuer leur contribution à la charge
commune alors évidemment le sujet est
désormais anciens et des progrès ont pu
être réalisés au cours des dernières
années
nous sommes cependant encore loin
d'avoir réglé le problème dans son
intégralité
d'où l'importance du texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui et en faveur
duquel les écologistes voteront
quoique avec quelques commentaires et
regret que j'explique citerai plus avant
là que l'accord fatca signé en novembre
dernier entre la france et les états
unis
nous devons aujourd'hui à prouver
renvoie la loi américaine du même nom
celle ci impose aux banques du monde
entier de signaler à l'administration
fiscale des états unis directement ou
par le biais comme c'est le cas ici des
administrations fiscales des pays où
elles opèrent
l'existence de comptes détenus chez
elles par des citoyens ou résidents
américains afin de détecter et donc
d'empêcher toute tentative d'évasion
fiscale précisons qu'une telle collecte
d'informations dans le cas de l'acteur
dont il est question ici se veut ta
terre réciproque des banques américaines
seront normalement tenus aux mêmes
obligations que leurs homologues
français
s'agissant de leurs citoyens qui
figurait parmi nos comptes pas de
s'agissant de leurs clients qui figurait
parmi nos concitoyens
cela équivaut dans les faits à
l'instauration d'un échange automatique
de données bancaires vieille
revendication des ong travaillant sur
ces questions et aussi des écologistes
au niveau européen cela facilitera
grandement le travail des gouvernements
de nos deux pays en la matière même si
on peut regretter que les comptes des
entreprises ne soient pour la plupart
pas concernés harcelé par cette mesure
c'est néanmoins il faut bien le
reconnaître une forme de révolution
copernicienne d'autant plus puissante
que les états unis sont en train de
conclure des accords du même type avec
de nombreux autres pays
reconnaissons qu'en la matière les
américains savent se rendent
particulièrement persuasif
en effet les activités sur leur
territoire des banques récalcitrantes
serait grandement menacée tandis que les
transactions des particuliers américains
qui ne seraient pas suffisamment
justifié serait frappé d'une retenue
punitive à hauteur de 30% de leur valeur
un impressionnant pouvoir de persuasion
qui a des retombées qu'ils étaient
encore inimaginables jusqu il y a
quelques années puisqu'il a mis sous
pression des acteurs comme le luxembourg
ou la suisse dont on peut dire qu'ils
sont historiquement peu friand de ce
genre d'exercice ceux ci ont d'ailleurs
dû se résoudre à signer des accords
semblables et leurs relations avec
d'autres états sont du même coup en
train de changer
mais j'irai plus loin c'est l'union
européenne
elle même qui est sous pression elle qui
n'était jamais parvenue jusqu'à la
avancer de manière satisfaisante pour
harmoniser un minimum les politiques
fiscales de ses états membres ni même
pour restreindre en son propre sein les
excès dus au secret bancaire
l'union européenne et la france ne
peuvent en effet que regretter qu'une
telle avancée n'ait été rendue possible
qu'à la suite de l'intervention d'un
tiers d'un pays tiers même si ce pays
tiers figurent parmi nos plus anciens
alliés
et même si la méthode qu'elle use un peu
spéciale est désormais récurrente
cela fait de nombreuses années que
l'europe aurait dû se doter de sa propre
loi fatca applicables d'abord et avant
tout sur son propre territoire et vers
certains de ses principaux partenaires
financiers
ces échecs domestique expliquant au
moins en partie son relatif effacement
au niveau international en la matière il
aura fallu la mise en place d'une
législation n'ont pas multilatéral
méharée américaine et visant à protéger
l'emploi et les finances publiques aux
états unis pour avancer sur ce dossier
alors même que la nature
extraterritoriale de certaines règles
édictées outre atlantique ont pu
émouvoir
il ya quelques semaines suite à l'amande
records affichés à une banque française
dans une affaire rappelons-le est
cependant bien différente
cela doit évidemment nous interpeller
l'europe ne peut plus continuer à se
construire de cette façon l'affluence
que devrait lui conférer son histoire et
son poids économique est décidément bien
trop facilement mise à mal par ses
propres divisions et par la mise en
concurrence des états qui la composent
c'est d'autant plus dommageable dans le
cas présent que la réciprocité dans la
transmission des informations rendues
possibles par set et corps ne sera pas
totale en tous les cas pas dans un
premier temps il faudra en effet
attendre une modification de la loi
américaine pour que solde bancaire et
valeur de rachat des contrats
d'assurance-vie bénéficiant aux
contribuables français installé aux
états unis soit transmis à notre propre
administration fiscale il ne s'agit
certes pas il ne s'agit certes que d'un
contretemps
espérons là nous sommes toutefois en
droit de le regretter car il est
illustratif du déséquilibre qui existe
entre nos deux pays et plus largement et
à nouveau entre états unis et union
européenne
ces quelques remarques formulées je
conclurai en réitérant évidemment le
soutien du groupe écologiste à ce texte
en espérant que l'échangé automatique de
données qu'il instaure entre nos deux
pays dans le respect bien sûr de la
protection de la vie privée puisse
devenir dans un avenir proche une règle
internationalement est effectivement
appliqué je vous remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole et à
madame nathalie goulet pour le groupe
u10 us et même président monsieur le
ministre ameur à porter mes chers
collègues je ne reviendrai donc pas sur
la présentation générale qui a été qui a
été fait monsieur le ministre vous avez
dit ce texte est novateur il est
novateur mais il est quand même
largement espéré il était largement
attendue et le voilà aux grands maux les
grands remèdes et d'une certaine façon
nos amis américains savent très bien le
faire après avoir mis à genoux les
banques suisses s'attaquent au reste du
système mondial on l'a vu récemment avec
la sphère de la bnp
c'est la version financière du big stick
le bâton plutôt que la carotte est donc
le gendarme outre-atlantique des amendes
massive et d interdiction de commercer
synonyme de ruines quasiment immédiate
le savoir faire américain en la matière
et d' absolument indéniable et
aujourd'hui il est clair que ce texte
était attendu comme je le dis tout à
l'heure est aussi très important mais il
nous permet monsieur le ministre de
dévier un peu puisque notre groupe
votera évidemment avec en train ce texte
était vice présidente de la commission
des enquêtes sur l'évasion fiscale
remarquablement rapportés par notre
collègue éric bocquet et et nous avons
de ce point de vue
un processus assez classique chaque fois
qu'il nous est possible à cette tribune
de rappeler un certain nombre de
principes qui ont été évoqués par cette
commission denquête nous ne manquons pas
une opportunité de le faire alors les
pénalités on a vu avec la bnp on a vu
avec les banques suisses le montant des
pénalités des affligés par les banques
américaines à titre de comparaison la mf
fait quand même pâle figure avec des
sanctions pécuniaires allant de 8000 à
14 millions d'euros 39 sanctions
simplement l'année dernière si l'on
compare avec la security and exchange
commission soit 688 actions pour 3
milliards de dollars dont vous voyez
qu'on ne boxe pas exactement dans la
même catégorie
et comme l'a dit le président marini
nous sommes quelque part dans la
diplomatie du dollar et manifestement il
faut aussi soumettre et c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec la bnp alors un certain
silence règne en france si l'on compare
avec la presse anglaise
l'économiste rappelé en 2013 que sept
millions d'américains vivent à
l'étranger
3000 expatriés en renoncer à la
citoyenneté américaine alan greene
cartes et plus de 1000 au seuil du
premier trimestre 2014 nous n'avons pas
seulement des exilés fiscaux français
qui pensent que la fiscalité est trop
grande nous avons aussi des américains
exilés qui considère que ce fatca va
poser un certain nombre de problèmes et
n'ont pas l'intention de s'y soumettre
d'ailleurs des banques ont préféré se
passer de clients américains tout
simplement afin de ne pas avoir à
remplir ses formulaires au plan
international la loi marque une
véritable inflexion dans cette
diplomatie du dollar on a dit
impérialisme judiciaire moi je plongerai
plutôt pour l'efficacité parce que sinon
on n'est pas capable de le faire
il faut attendre l'europe il faut
toujours qu'on attende et monsieur le
ministre
nous avons quand même des outils alors
je voudrais je voudrais simplement vous
rappelez vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
des assurances vie on a parlé du fichier
ficoba donc je voudrais quand même vous
rappelez vous n'étiez pas à ce banc mais
il se trouve que le 18 juillet dans ce
même hémicycle
j'avais déposé un amendement qui était
un amendement commun avec éric bocquet
de façon est-ce qu'on complète le
fichier ficoba par le fichier des
assurances vie de façon à faire un petit
fatca au national et le ministre 15,9
m'a répondu en matière bancaire c'est
une excellente manière la traçabilité
nous souhaitons mettre en oeuvre cette
mesure en liaison étroite avec les
compagnies d'assurance
nous sommes en concertation avec elle
pour parvenir à la faveur de la réforme
de la fiscalité de l'assurance vie qui
interviendra dans les prochaines
semaines en conséquence je vous suggère
madame boulet de retirer votre
amendement est d'attendre que la
concertation a boutique puisse reprendre
cette disposition c'est en page 7441 du
journal officiel du 18 juillet dernier
donc le journal non mais le fatca avec
les américains c'est très bien mais nous
avons des outils nationaux qui peuvent
aussi remplir un certain nombre de
missions dans un gruyère puisque il est
parfaitement non pas prévisions à la
suisse bien sûr mais simplement pour
dire qu' il est parfaitement évident que
ce que le travail qu'on essaye de faire
les parlementaires le gouvernement et
l'ensemble des gens qui travaillent y
compris le cd eux c'est de faire en
sorte que des gens ne passe pas à
travers les mailles du filet alors le
président marini parler de l'iran moi je
rentre du golfe et ce qui n'était
absolument pas concevable ni aduba il
n'ya bouddha binya chargea c'est à dire
que des citoyens américains avaient des
bancs des comptes en toute quiétude sont
maintenant obligés de passer exactement
par les mêmes fourches caudines que les
autres et donc c'est bon que sont en
train ou simplement de renvoyer leurs
clients aux états unis en tous les cas
de remplir les obligations du fait qu'à
faute de quoi un certain nombre de
contrats ou un certain nombre de
couvertures notamment militaires
ricken ne se feront plus sentir encore
une fois le big stick fonctionne et à un
endroit où on ne s'y attendait pas alors
évidemment la commission des finances a
auditionné le président du comité fiscal
de la fédération bancaire qui a
évidemment mis en exergue les frais et
les coûts de la mise en place de ce
système pour deux cent mille comptes
bancaires soit quelques à peu près 200
ou 300 millions d'euros pour une
adaptation
il est parfaitement évident qu'il faudra
là aussi prendre les mesures les mesures
nécessaires alors dans la grande
bataille de l'évasion fiscale l'échangé
automatique d'informations entre les
administrations fait évidemment est une
nécessité d autres initiatives on en a
parlé tout à l'heure à de marie
escoffier on a parlé aussi des récents
développements à l' ocde
donc je ne vais pas revenir là dessus
le cds est inspirée de la loi fatca donc
encore une fois et et en toute hypothèse
là aussi il va falloir minimiser les
coûts pour la place de paris
moi j'aurais pratiquement terminé en
disant que l' ocde veut accélérer le
calendrier donc il faut que nous
prenions un certain nombre de
dispositions il ne faut pas que dans la
prochaine loi de finances si par bonheur
nous pouvons l'examiner dans son
intégralité et que nous proposions un
certain nombre de mesures elles sont
encore repoussés aux calendes grecques
au motif que l'europe n'a pas décidé ou
que l'europe n'a pas fait ou que nous
sommes tous seuls
je pense que ce texte prouve quand on a
une initiative valable
on arrive quand même à obtenir un
certain nombre de résultats alors
moi j'ai deux questions à vous poser qui
sont presque une consultation personnel
parce que j'ai deux enfants qui vivent
aux états unis voyez-vous et je me
posais la question et je me posais la
question de nos collègues français
vivant à l'étranger et la façon dont ce
texte allait s'appliquer à leur compte
bancaire et de la même façon nous avons
aussi auditionné un certain nombre de
célébrités dans notre commission
denquête n'est ce pas cher éric bocquet
de gens qui prétendument vivent à
l'étranger mais qui en fait passe la
majeure partie de leur temps à en france
et qui risque finalement d'avoir un
certain nombre de problèmes donc le jeu
je m'interrogeais pour savoir dans
quelle mesure ce texte allait toucher
les français de l'étranger
je crois que c'est une disposition
importante qu'il faut quand même soulevé
et puis et puis aussi évidemment les
territoires non coopératifs sur lesquels
il faudra encore naturellement m mettre
la pression
donc évidemment c'est important on a
signalé au passage tout à l'heure les
prix de transfert on a mentionné ou en
tous les cas évoqués le traité
transatlantique qui va arriver
nous ne sommes pas du tout avec ce texte
dans la même situation au nid dans le
même contexte il s'agit d'un texte
extrêmement important que nous appelions
de nos voeux et que nous soutenons dans
notre groupe dans son intégralité je
remercie merci madame la sénatrice dans
la suite la discussion générale la
parole et à monsieur éric bocquet pour
le groupe src
bien vers le président tu me lis mes
chers collègues
c'est un petit bonheur en cette fin de
session parlementaire de pouvoir voter
un texte qui va dans le bon sens avec
quelques bémols
je m'en expliquerai plus loin mais un
vote positif certainement presque re la
discussion ce jour porte sur
l'approbation de l'accord communément
appelée fatca qui vise donc à instaurer
un système d'échangé automatique
d'informations entre administrations
fiscales donc de la france d'une part et
des états unis d'autre part ce débat
bien sûr c'est rétro rappeler ne peut
que réjouir les membres des commissions
d enquête que notre groupe avait initiée
et donc j'ai eu l'honneur et le plaisir
être le rapporteur en effet l'un des
constats que nous avions pu faire à
l'issue de ces travaux était d'abord
l'idée que l'une des armes absolues dans
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
internationale et la transparence
incontestablement le dispositif fatca
marque une avancée importante dans cette
direction cette convention entente elle
ne pose pas de problème majeur et
participe de l'effort accompli depuis
plusieurs années pour tenter de lutter
contre la fraude l'évasion et
l'optimisation fiscale
la méthode américaine fait évidemment
débat aux états unis pays souvent
présenté comme un paradis libéral mais
qui en l'occurrence nous montre que
libéralisme et laisser-faire absolue
sont deux notions qui diffère quelque
peu
la crise des subprimes explique en
partie ce besoin
il y avait les états unis de tenter de
récupérer de la matière fiscale qui
étaient nécessaires pour faire face à
leurs propres difficultés économiques et
aussi à la réalité des inégalités
sociales croissantes dans le pays on
pourrait qualifier cette démarche de
pragmatique car elle ne dédouane en rien
une certaine schizophrénie de la
ministre américaine dont la miss
nationale qu'elle fait preuve en
tolérant les régimes fiscaux très
favorable de certains états américains
comme le delaware le wyoming et le
nevada ou encore la présence de très
grands groupes industriels américains
aux îles caïmans ou aux bermudes qui ne
fut dire qu'il ne figure plus soit dit
en passant sur la liste française des
paradis fiscaux depuis le début de cette
année
tous ces éléments de contexte côté
américain ne peuvent que nous engager à
soutenir l'appel à la vigilance exprimé
par notre rapporte michel andré qui a
attiré l'attention du gouvernement
notamment sur la question de la
compatibilité des normes entre elles
ceci me permet d'évoquer à cet instant
la passionnante auditions de monsieur
jérôme haas président de l'autorité des
normes comptables malheureusement
récemment décédé qui avait démontré en
face de la commission avec beaucoup de
clarté à quel point aujourd'hui dans le
monde de la finance
ce sont les normes comptables anglo
saxon qui s'impose dans la finance
mondialisée alors oui il ya bien là un
point de vigilance qu'il était important
de souligner cet accord fait cas
constitue donc un point d'appui pour la
france mais doit aussi permettre
d'avancer vers ce fameux standard
international que tous les états
semblent appeler de leurs voeux
aujourd'hui c'est à dire l'échangé
automatique d'informations entre tous
les états mais pragmatisme et
volontarisme ne suffiront pas chacun le
sait pertinemment depuis septembre 2009
date à laquelle l'ancien président de la
république décréta avec fracas à la fin
des paradis fiscaux
beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous les ponts
mais aussi beaucoup d'argent liquide
s'est déversé dans les coffres des
banques des paradis fiscaux
ainsi entre 2007 et 2012 le montant des
avoirs privés placé hors des frontières
est passé de 7300 milliards de dollars à
8500 la suisse reste championne du monde
qui passe de 1971 milliards à 2200 pour
représenter 26% du total
le royaume uni avec jersey guernesey
l'île de man et nous ajouterons la
capitale de l'irlande dublin passant de
1750 2 milliards à 2000 milliards
représentant 24% du total ou encore les
caraïbes et panama 2022 milliards à 1200
pour un total de 14 % du total des
avoirs expatriés
nous le voyons bien mes chers collègues
les craintes parfois exprimées ici sur
le risque de surcoût que générait la
mise en oeuvre de fat cas ne pèse pas
bien lourd au regard des trésors
accumulés dans les paradis fiscaux aux
mondiaux si le dispositif fatca semble
avoir le soutien unanime au cendre
rassemblés il n'en est pas de même pour
les citoyens américains concernés saleh
d'être rappelé en effet fatah a déjà
envoyé une certaine onde de choc parmi
les sept millions d'américains vivent à
l'étranger
de nombreuses banques s'était rappelée
par notre collègue nathalie goulet leur
ont déjà fait savoir qu'elle préférait
ne pas les avoir comme client car cela
demanderait trop de travail de remplir
les formulaires de l'administration
fiscale américaine lient rs cette
conception me laisse un peu pantois
à l'époque où un simple clic de souris
suffit pour transférer des millions
d'euros à l'autre bout de la planète
visiblement pour certaines banques la
règle c'est travailler moins pour gagner
plus
du côté des réticences ou résistance à
cette nouvelle règle de transparence
nous noterons effectivement la décision
de 3000 expatriés américains qui ont
renoncé en 2013 à leur citoyenneté ou à
leur carte verte et plus de 1000 au
premier trimestre de cette année contre
une centaine par an avant l'adoption de
fatca un américain ayant double la
société hollandaise a même gagné son
procès contre une banque qui avait
autoritairement fermer son compte
il faut néanmoins enclenché la mise en
oeuvre du dispositif fatca s'en servir
comme point d'appui pour promouvoir un
fat cas européen on ne perdant pas de
vue l'objectif ultime prônée par l' ocde
de l' échange multilatéral d'information
et d'imposition basé sur le territoire
et non sur la nationalité gageons que
sur ce sujet le soutien de monsieur jean
claude juncker ancien dirigeant d'un
paradis fiscal notoire au coeur de
l'europe nous sera acquis dans le cadre
des nouvelles responsabilités qui
viennent de lui être confiée cette
remarque ne se veut pas anecdotique
ni humoristiques n'est accessoires elle
pose me semble-t-il une vraie question
politique quant à la capacité et la
volonté politique de l'union européenne
de combattre résolument fraude et
évasion fiscale mais ce jeune caire a
dirigé pendant 18 ans le luxembourg pays
où sévissent et secret bancaire et
opacité des structures juridiques
la question du luxembourg se posent et
se posera encore au sein de l'union
européenne
partenaire historique de la construction
ainsi tout récemment une décision du
tribunal administratif de luxembourg
s'est fendu coup sur coup le 16 juin
deux jugements qui devrait faire date
dans la délimitation du champ du secret
professionnel opposable dans la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale
l'histoire en deux mots un avocat
français soupçonnés de fraude fiscale a
été protégé par son secret professionnel
en tant qu'avocat ce qui a permis à
l'administration fiscale luxembourg de
ne pas autoriser la banque à ouvrir ces
informations comment ne pas poser non
plus la question de cette règle de
l'unanimité
notre collègue madame escoffier l'a fait
sur les sujets fiscaux en vigueur au
sein de l'union européenne
un seul étape toujours aujourd'hui se
poser à toute avancée effectivement en
matière de transparence ce que le
luxembourg et l'autriche ne se sont pas
privés de faire à propos de la directive
épargne
chacun mesure bien ici les chantiers
multiples qu'il conviendra d'ouvrir pour
donner aux dispositifs fatca sa pleine
et entière efficacité fatca est un
premier pas important certes mais un
premier pas sur le chemin de la
transparence
c'est un combat qui nous concerne tous
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
s'y est d'ores et déjà engagé avec
détermination avec beaucoup d'autres
vous pouvez compter sur notre ténacité
animé que nous sommes de la volonté de
défendre l'intérêt de la république donc
l'intérêt général notre groupe votera
très logiquement en faveur de la
ratification de l'accord foreign account
tax compliance act
merci merci monsieur le sénateur dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à madame nicole bricq pour le
groupe socialiste président
mes chers collègues monsieur secrétaire
d'état voudrait remercier madame la
rapporteur michel andré qui dans son
propos liminaire a fait référence à son
opiniâtreté passé ap l'été a plaidé pour
un fat cas de ce côté ci de l'atlantique
voir alpha de cannes national
et c'est vrai que j'ai répertorié pas
moins de cinq batailles conduite au nom
du groupe socialiste depuis 2010
elles furent menées mais elles furent
perdu du temps nous étions dans la
minorité et j'ai noté monsieur le
président marini vous étiez alors
rapporteur général que lors de cet
assaut c'était celui du 28 novembre 2011
avec l'amendement que je présentais vous
en aviez reconnu l'intention louable
mais vous n'en aviez demandé le retrait
et je vous avais dit alors vous y
viendrez et je crois que d'une certaine
manière nous y sommes ce soir alors je
dois à la vérité historique que la
france faisait partie des cinq états
membres de l'union européenne qui
s'était entendu le 5 février 2012 en
pleine campagne électorale
présidentielle pour signer des accords
bilatéraux d'échangé d'information entre
leur administration fiscale et
l'administration américaine sur leur
lancée les cinq le groupe des 5 1 avait
demandé à la commission européenne de
proposer un système d échange de
renseignements sur le modèle fat cas ce
qui fut fait le 12 juin 2013 par la
révision de la directive 2011 16 1 e
et c'est la présidence italienne
contemporaine qui en assurera
l'efficacité et qui verra à réprimer les
ardeurs dilatoire d'états membres
récalcitrants
nous les connaissons ils ont été cités
ce soir par les orateurs qui m'ont
précédé et c'est vrai aussi que sur le
sol national
le texte de régulation bancaire est
entré en application en août 2013
il introduit dans notre droit national
l'échangé automatique à la faveur des
conventions fiscales signées par la
france avec les états étrangers
c'est pierre moscovici qui a signé la
convention fatca avec les états unis le
14 novembre 2013
et c'est ce soir la ratification de ce
qui est un traité international
alors si j'ai rappelé cette genèse c'est
qu'elle nous fait mesurer le temps
politique
kim il ya entre la volonté et la
décision
et je voudrais rappeler à cet égard que
c'est au plus fort de la crise
financière que les pays du g20
rassemblés à londres avait décidé en
2009 de mettre à l'agenda prioritaires
la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux et
d'une manière plus générale la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale 2009 et je ne
sais pas s'il y a quelques rescapés de
ce que nous appelions le groupe des 24
camp du député et 12 sénateurs de toutes
couleurs se réunissent et régulièrement
j'ai repris les notes que les
recommandations que nous avions faite et
évidemment la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale figuraient depuis le début de
nos travaux et c'était une très bonne
initiative parlementaire prêt à
l'initiative des drones présidents du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale
alors j'ai bien noté aussi qu'il y à
encore oui absolument absolument c'était
une autre majorité
il y a encore des interrogations et des
réticences
j'en ai retenu quelques unes la question
est posée de savoir si ce n'est pas la
lex americana qui s'impose au monde
parce que les états unis sont puissants
et c'est vrai que eux-mêmes ont
introduit des après un an à peine après
le g20 de londres cette législation
dès 2010 on peut s'interroger
effectivement sur cette puissance
américaine
on peut aussi s'interroger sur le
principe d'extraterritorialité de la loi
américaine qui a été mise en évidence
par la lourde sanction qui fera qui
frappe un de nos fleurons bancaires et
nous pouvons nous poser la question cela
ne contrevient t-il pas à ce qui est
notre principe de la nationalité
mais la belle affaire les états unis on
ne découvre pas aujourd'hui qu'il met le
droit et la fiscalité au service
la compétitivité de leur entreprise ce
n'est pas une découverte pour nous mais
que ne le faisons nous pas de ce côté ci
de l'atlantique
je pense que l'union européenne est
encore la première puissance commerciale
du monde
elle aurait des atouts à faire valoir
elle a la capacité à produire des normes
et du droit et elle ne s'en prive pas
encore faut-il qu'elles le fassent sur
l'essentiel est qu'elles le mettent à la
portée des entreprises européennes
alors évidemment on peut avoir aussi
j'ai bien noté des réticences des
milieux bancaires
car effectivement ça leur demande une
adaptation et toute adaptation entraîne
des frais et quelque peu onéreuse mais
les banques
je pense à la fbf française elle si j'ai
rappelé l'historique c'est quand même
elles ont eu l'occasion
elles ont eu le temps de s'adapter et du
reste j'avais bien noté que l'industrie
bancaire américaine a était vent debout
longtemps contre la législation sade cas
il a fallu le port de l'opiniâtreté du
congrès et du président obama pour y
arriver mais spontanément elle n'était
pas tout emballé alors des résistances
subsistent subsistent et je pense
qu'elles sont très légitimes concernant
la portée de la réciprocité car elle
n'est pas totale dans la convention
fiscale et des craintes s'expriment sur
le fait de dépendre du bon vouloir du
débat du sénat américain
cela aussi c'est légitime mais je
voudrais rappeler que hier 21 juillet
l'os et des oeufs a publié sa norme ou
la réciprocité est totale elle sera
officiellement présenté au prochain g20
sous présidence australienne à kembs les
20 et 21 septembre
soixante cinq pays et territoires se
sont publiquement engagés à mettre en
oeuvre cette norme mondiale
d'autres pourraient suivre à l'occasion
du forum monde
et al sur la transparence et l'échangé
de renseignements fiscaux qui sera
organisée à berlin à la fin du mois
d'octobre
à l'initiative du ministre des finances
allemand et je pense que nous allons
disposer d'un standard international qui
fera référence alors il faut donc faire
confiance à la volonté politique et à la
force aussi des pressions convergentes
pour arriver à une application pleine et
entière de ce standard
je ne doute pas que la mobilisation des
associations michel andré ya fait
référence tout à l'heure qui a été
entière depuis le début ce qu'on appelle
la société civile bien improprement et
ces associations sont engagées de longue
date dans le combat de la transparence
fiscale
elle sera au rendez vous je pense je ne
les vois pas abandonner ce combat
qu'elle mène depuis des années alors que
nous touchons au but alors il n'a pas
manqué d pitt est encore tout à l'heure
à cette tribune pour qualifier cet
acronyme fatca j'ai entendu tremblement
de terre séisme bombe
bon sans aller jusqu à ces extrêmes il
faut bien constater que la vague venue
de ce côté-là de l'atlantique a fait
bouger les choses de ce côté ci combien
de fois mais nous sommes nous pas la
menthe et de l'absence de révision de la
directive épargne de 2003 ou deux états
membres l'autriche et le luxembourg pour
ne pas les citer avait obtenu de
s'exonérer de la pleine application de
cette directive c'est bien ça qu'à qui a
fait tomber les murs de secret bancaire
encore en vigueur à l'intérieur même de
la zone euro quand j'étais rapporteur
général nous étions allés en autriche et
je me souviens du plaidoyer que ce soit
à gauche ou à droite
c'était l'identité nationale qui
reposaient dans ce secret bancaire c'est
pas vieux c'était au début de l'année
eh bien on voit bien que les choses ont
bougé
même dans ce pays très attachés au
secret bancaire
alors pour terminer
la concrétisation d'un projet espéré
mais moullec a utilisé cette est attendu
doit l'emporter sur les réticences
fut-elle fusse-t-elle légitime
le groupe socialiste se suivra d'autant
mieux madame la rapporteur qui l'a
précédé dans sa volonté de prendre appui
sur fadq a déjà depuis longtemps dans sa
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
et comme madame andrée et notre
rapporteur mais elle était et elle est
membre du groupe socialiste
nos volontés se rejoignent et vraiment
c'est de très bon coeur que nous
ratifierons ce traité au nom du sénat et
du groupe socialiste je vous remercie
merci merci madame la ministre dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur francis delattre
pour le groupe ump
voilà le président monsieur le ministre
en réalité il s'agit de ratifier
bon j'ai deux doigts d'un accord déjà
conclu entre la france et les états unis
et c'est un accord qui fixe un cadre aux
années qui viennent pour la mise en
oeuvre d' échange automatique
d'informations entre la france et les
états unis sur les revenus les activent
contribuables on croit savoir qu'un à
130 140 me français dont un tiers temps
ayant la double nationalité aux états
unis et 100 mille américains
je crois que c'est les chiffres qui sont
les rapports souray dira que la notre
groupe à l'exception du président
retrace ce projet mme smith nous
permettra de terminer la journée sera si
intéressant vous dire quand même que
cette ratification c'est quand même pas
bretton-woods à bretton woods c'est
l'arc s'est installé en réalité
l'impérialisme du dollar il ne faut pas
confondre avec un accord international
et en réalité c'est impérialisme qui
perdure dans les échanges puisque le
dollar fait 4 1 % des échanges et qu'on
doit on faire entre case qu'un 16%
ça vient aussi de notre incapacité à
imposer l'euro comme monnaie essentiel
des échanges du monde c'est tout aussi
tailles toutes nos hésitations
européennes
et quand on on s'alarme la puissance de
l'oncle sam
c'est vrai qu'elle est puissant mais
c'est vrai aussi qu'il nous rend service
parce qu'en réalité le paradis fiscal la
notion de paradis fiscal
le premier pas de géant qui a été fait
c'est quand les états unis on comptera
ubs grandes banques suisses à faire en
sorte de renoncer au secret fiscal
et ils étaient ensuite très difficile à
ce paradis notoire de dire à ses voisins
européens
nous n'allons pas vous faire bénéficier
des mêmes avantages que ce que nous
permettons maintenant dans les échanges
avec les états unis
c'est là monsieur le ministre c'est à
partir de là comme un an j'avais les
dossiers fiscaux et vous nous annoncez
presque des ressources pérennes sur les
sur les avoirs de certains nos
compatriotes à l'étranger
donc je dirais même j'ose même dire que
l'embargo économique les embargos que
deux
qui sont diligentées à l'échelle
internationale et où les états unis sont
toujours naturellement le levier le plus
puissant sont très utiles aujourd'hui
dans nos rapports internationaux et
aujourd'hui monsieur poutine
il grimpe à nos canons ni nos chars il
craint des sanctions économiques donc
une grande banque qui se permet de
transgresser les règles internationales
elle manque à son devoir de solidarité
pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
organiser les relations internationales
sans pour autant verser le sang donc ce
projet est un très bon projet le but est
faire payer effectivement les impôts aux
états unis bien sûr on a bien compris
alors à tout ce qui a été dit je devrai
simplement à dire que le bras c'est
quand même à tout américain qui
transgresserait une retenue à la source
de 30% sur les flux financiers des états
unis vers les comptes à l'étranger qui
pourraient être perçues pour que les
états unis en réalité non seulement les
impose au monde à sa tombe de leurs
règles mais ils sont intransigeants
aussi pour ce les imposées en interne
malgré la complexité de l'état fédéral
est une des raisons pour lesquelles ça
fonctionne c'est qu'en réalité les
jeunes justice e indépendance et que on
voit bien même quelques années après
certes on voit bien comme l'a dit le
rapporteur tout à l'heure que sur les
seuls pran aujourd'hui l'amendé
colossale
alors que nous le crédit lionel ça fait
18 ans qu'on traîne une affaire qui
n'est pas encore réglé alors essayons de
faire en sorte de ne pas toujours donner
des leçons alors que le sens bien du mal
et on europe
et d'ailleurs c'est assez paradoxal de
voir que c'est les accords fatca qui
font que l'europe avance enfin pour elle
même avoir un système interne entre tous
les états de l'europe
qui permet un échange intéressant est
facile qui va se mettre en place gare
grâce bien sûr aux fameuses à cornes
dont a parlé madame briques du j5 mais
aussi et surtout parce que nous avons
fait en sorte que même madame la
chancelière allemande
on a ces accords bilatéraux avec la
suisse 10 ans a récupéré une
rémunération sur les comptes bancaires
allemands logés dans les comptes des
banques suisses alors je crois que c'est
quand même extraordinaire qu'on se plaît
quelque part on se plaint en disant
quand même nous impose des choses cfc tu
aimeras au départ mais aujourd'hui dans
les tous les effets en cascade on
s'aperçoit que ça va nous servir ça va
servir l'europe à se constituer
peut-être qu'après on va enfin on va
avancer
pour m une europe financières
budgétaires et fiscales à peu près en
ordre et faire en sorte que comme l'a
dit me brille que cette première
puissance économique par une monnaie qui
compte enfin la hauteur de ce qu'elle
est économiquement dans le monde et je
lis à même à monsieur le ministre que en
réalité
brett hull soul salsa le sert
aujourd'hui parce qu'en réalité ils font
marcher la planche à billets à fond
depuis deux trois ans pour soutenir
l'activité économique mondiale et
notamment des pays dits émergents qui ne
demande qu'une chose c'est de venir
submergeant la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cette abondance de
liquidités dans le monde font que l'état
français peut emprunter de vraies
conditions extraordinairement favorables
c'est encore un des effets de
l'impérialisme de nos amis et alliés
américains sur le président les
résidents américains à l'étranger
doivent aussi ainsi faire une
déclaration
le système américain est quand même
assystem sur lesquels les européens vont
devoir travailler parce qu'en réalité le
l'américain titraille à l'étranger fait
une déclaration doit faire une
déclaration
si la nationalité américaine auprès du
fisc américain et il déduit tous les
impôts ou taxes que la pays dans les
pays où ils travaillent
alors ce système correspond
effectivement à leur système qui est lui
déjà largement mondialisée alors que
nous on est toujours attaché au système
dit des territoires eh bien écoutez avec
la mondialisation qui s'annonce
mes chers collègues la folle a peut-être
qu'on s'intéresse à faire la
contrepartie de fat cas qui est qu'on a
un système nous aussi où les français
travaillant à l'étranger est une double
déclaration fiscale pour qu'on puisse
nous aussi avoir un système qui
correspondent à une perception qui est
conforme à ce qu'est aujourd'hui le
monde économique alors s'arrête la
deuxième partie intéressante ça vient
demander 10 ans là aussi mais sa
collègue mais en tous les cas c'est la
voix qui est inévitable à partir de mots
aussi une faute quand notre système
fiscal devra être profondément modifiée
si on veut faire en sorte que comme tous
les états développés on n'assiste pas
une évasion fiscale de nos bases
fiscales qui est alarmante pour
l'ensemble des finances publiques
donc c'est plus de soixante dix sept
mille banques dans le monde qui se sont
engagés à collaborer avec les états unis
est ce qu'il y aura sur nous c'est
l'implication de l'eau cdo qui quand
même l'instrument nous avons reçu 1 la
commission représentant en france de l'
ocde et on sent bien que le projet ils
sont prêts les manager techniquement ils
ont réussi à imposer aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle un standard le standard ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
des règles compréhensible donc auquel on
peut quand elles sont simples et
compréhensibles
on peut difficilement y échapper alors
nous dire nous disons pour pour
justifier parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été liés à cette heure ci sur la
technique c'est ce qui va faire dans
leurs parties en éclats fait d'accord en
ce que vous avez dit vous dire que nous
pensons que ça constituera pour les
prochaines années un outil majeur les
accords pas le cas pour de lutter contre
la fraude et l'évasion fiscale et on
voit bien les états unis les problèmes
eux aussi qu'ils ont avec leurs grandes
multinationales actuellement et que ces
réflexions qu'ils ont on devra aussi les
avoir car en europe nous sommes quand
même le seul pays qui est l'équivalent
du cac 40
notre économie notre dispositif est
différent de l'allemagne qui a beaucoup
de pme pmi mais nous nous avons la
chance d'avoir des grandes entreprises
nationales dites du cac 40
en suisse nous relevons que les bouches
d'une gouvernance mondiale sur ces
sujets donne du relief aussi à ces
assemblées du g20 qui sont souvent
perçues par nos concitoyens comme un
aéropage de des dignitaires et fort peu
préoccupé intéressés par la régulation
là au moins il ya un contenu
saluons aussi la technicité gelid ocde
qui est la cheville ouvrière d'un projet
qui va progressivement s'installer comme
un standard mondial d échange
automatique d'informations bancaires et
khalid et aux séries du même le
rapporteur que 45 pays sont déjà
impliqués mais khalid l ocde dit que 60
déjà travail autour du projet et que à
partir d'un chiffre aussi considérable
de considérer que rapidement c'est 80%
des échanges qui seront mondiaux
concernés enfin il faut bien le dire
monsieur le président la commission des
finances
surprise aux surprises salon aussi les
décisions effectivement du deuil du
conseil ecofin du 14 mai 2013 où la
france et ses principaux partenaires
d'allemagne l'espagne nous ont convaincu
la commission d'engager un projet
multilatéral équivalent dispositif fatca
et avec le standard de l' ocde
cette articulation avec le droit de
l'union européenne permettra la jce mans
souhaitable de nos propres échanges
entre l'état de l'union européenne et je
dirais qu'il ya peut-être qu'un seul
petit bémol
emportés à ce dispositif et là c'est au
législateur de faire attention parce
qu'on avait été transféré des données à
caractère personnel
un pays tiers pose effectivement des
problèmes diverses
nous avons été les créateurs la première
loi informatique et libertés en 1900 sur
118 je crois au prix par l'interactive
européennes ont pris améliorée depuis
il faut faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des documents techniques qui seront
utilisés dans ces échanges il faisait le
label de la cnil voilà la seule
recommandation que je ferai en disant
monsieur le ministre nous allons enfin
terminé plus soirée en vous donnant
quelque part satisfaction si monsieur le
sénateur dernier orateur inscrivent dans
la discussion générale monsieur jacques
chiron pour le groupe socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission madame la rapporteure chers
collègues nous avons souvent dit ici
selon les meilleures estimations
milliards d'euros par an échappe à
l'administration fiscale européenne soit
une moyenne de 2000 euros par an et par
européen à l'échelle nationale on le
sait c'est entre 60 et 80 milliard cette
fraude est le fait de ceux qui ont les
moyens de s'offrir des services de
fiscalistes qui élabore des mécanismes
toujours plus complexes d'évasion
fiscale pour se soustraire à leurs
obligations légales de contribution à la
solidarité nationale
alors où les demandé à chacun de faire
des efforts et donc absolument
indispensable tant au niveau moral que
comptable de mener un combat
ininterrompu contre la dette contre
cette délinquance qui est un véritable
affront au parc social national ce
combat il passe nous l'avons tous types
art une époque par une réponse
coordonnée et cohérente de l'ensemble
des acteurs publics l'occasion messi
donnait de rappeler le travail des
commissions d enquête sur l'évasion
fiscale que nous avons mises en place au
sénat dès novembre 2011 d'une part et
sur le rôle des acteurs financiers dans
l'évasion des capitaux d'autre part ces
travaux nous ont permis de décrire en
état des lieux objective et d'identifier
les véritables hausses obstacles
juridiques politiques techniques à la
transparence et la régulation de mettre
en lumière des pistes de travail et de
décliner des propositions dont certaines
sont aujourd'hui traduites en mesures
juridiquement opposable
d'ailleurs à l'époque quand nous avions
terminé en juin 2012
si on nous arrive si on nous avait dit
qu'aujourd'hui nous en sommes nous en
serions là je crois que nous aurions
tous tous étaient sceptiques
il faut aussi le reconnaître qu'on de
deux ans le travail et les efforts ont
été considérables ce travail a permis au
gouvernement de se saisir des questions
de fiscalité internationale et nous nous
en félicitons que le travail accompli
depuis lors et permis de dépasser le
stade de bonnes intentions et de
réellement resserrer les mailles du
filet de la justice de la juste heureux
régulation le durcissement des peines la
dotation de nouveaux moyens techniques
et humains pour poursuivre les fraudeurs
et plus globalement la promesse que la
contrainte public ne faiblira pas
produit aujourd'hui des résultats en
témoignent les chiffres encourageants du
nombre de dossiers de demande de
régularisation reçue au ministère de
l'économie et des finances qui a pas
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez dit
plus de 25 mille demandes preuves
provenant principalement de suisse mais
aussi du luxembourg pour environ un
milliard d'euros de recettes et un
milliard huit d'ici la fin de l'année
dans cette démarche la france a donc des
alliés sensibilisés par la crise
financière mais également par des
opinions publiques qui légitimement ne
supporte plus que la fraude et l'évasion
et que de nombreux états se sont donc en
des engagés pour plus de transparence et
de coopération entre leur administration
parmi eux les états unis on l'a dit ont
joué un rôle fondamental de pression sur
les états pratiquant le secret bancaire
et la fiscalité privilégiée
la puissance de négociation américaine
et sans doute aussi la peur des
représailles
des établissements financiers a permis
la signature d'accords entre les états
unis et des dizaines de pays parmi
lesquels la suisse et le luxembourg
de plus rappelons-nous l'enterrement des
accords dits rubik unnim unanimement
crédité dans leurs principes en france
mais dont on parlait encore il ya à
peine deux trois ans nous permet d'être
raisonnablement optimiste sur la
réussite de notre objectif qui est la
généralisation du principe de
transmission obligatoire et automatique
des données bancaires au niveau de
l'europe donc plus de transparence qui
doit peser de tout son poids dans cette
démarche
puis à l'échelle mondiale et selon des
termes identiques pour tous la
convention bilatérale fadq a signé avec
les états unis le 14 novembre 2013 et
qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui de ratifier
permet plusieurs types d'avancées
majeures directement d'abord par la mise
en place du principe d' échange
automatique d informations et qui
permettra de sortir de la logique de la
coopération à la demande
désormais l'administration fiscale sera
automatiquement et systématiquement
informés des ouvertures de comptes
transferts de fonds création de sociétés
de nos compatriotes aux états unis même
en dehors de toute procédure
administratif ou judiciaire
il s'agira toutefois certains d'entre
nous l'ont dit d'être vigilant sur
l'application réelle d'une réciprocité
parfaite entre nos deux états en ne
perdant pas de vue que les pratiques des
états unis en matière de transmission
d'informations sur demande ont fait
l'objet de réserves à l'occasion du
forum fiscal de jakarta en novembre 2013
réserve qui visait principalement
d'ailleurs l'état du deleware
indirectement ensuite parce que c'est
ratification intervient à un moment
charnière où le rapport de forces à
l'échelle mondiale a été
incontestablement bouleversé les états
les plus traditionnellement réticents à
la transparence bancaire qu'ils soient
membres de l'union européenne on l'a dit
le luxembourg l'autriche ou non la suite
la suisse le liechtenstein se retrouve
de plus en plus isolé
l'idée d' échange automatique d
informations se retrouvent renforcer sur
l'impulsion du g20 le cd oeuvre dans la
généralisation du principe d'échangé
automatique qui deviendra un standard
international beaucoup d'entre vous
l'ont dit permettant une réponse
cohérente et adaptée au secret bancaire
à la dissimulation d avoir ce standard
on l'a dit a été publiée hier par l'
ocde et doit être adopté par le par les
ministres des finances du g20 de
septembre prochain
nous espérons du ministre que la france
maintiendra son rôle de force motrice
dans cette démarche
comme il l'a fait depuis deux ans
parallèlement la france et ses
partenaires du g5 se sont engagés en
faveur du renforcement du film et du
civisme fiscal en proposant la révision
de la directive sur la coopération
administrative dans le domaine fiscal
sur la base de l'application de la
clause de la nation la plus favorisée la
révision de cette directive doit nous
amener à consacrer la règle de
transmission automatique des
informations à l'échelle de l'union et
adopter des règles communes vis-à-vis
des pays tiers comme le rappelait le
ministre de l'économie
d'ailleurs en 2013 ici cette négociation
devra aboutir sous la présidence
italienne du conseil de l'union
nous comptons sur mini sur votre
vigilance pour que l'accord conclu le
soit sur des bases ambitieuse il est en
effet fondamental que l'europe parle
d'une seule voix est claire sur ce sujet
elle aura d'ailleurs autant de puissance
et de poids à ce moment là que les états
unis on parle toujours de notre
puissance par rapport aux états unis
mais si si l'europe était soudée sa
puissance serait équivalente au niveau
européen le processus de révision de la
directive de fiscalité d'epargne s'est
accéléré une version révisée a été
adopté par le conseil le 24 mars dernier
et intègre une extension de son champ
d'application
le périmètre initialement limitée aux
revenus d'épargné des particuliers est
désormais étendu aux produits
d'assurance vie ce texte qu'on s'attend
nous plaît échange automatique
d'informations
entre états membres étant due aux très
hautes aussi aux fondations et autres
sociétés écrans je me rappelle le débat
à l'époque en 2011 2012
on ne l'espérait pas il s'agit là encore
d'un pas décisif vers la fin du secret
bancaire en europe
autorisé par l'émergence d'un standard
partagé qui a permis la levée des
réticences autrichienne et
luxembourgeoises jessains grévin ocde
l'union européenne partout les lignes
bougent les obstacles d'hier s'effrite
les verrous sautent sous la pression de
la communauté internationale organisée
dans ce combat la france est en première
ligne et occupe une position
volontariste qui produit
particulièrement ses effets depuis que
2012 et nous pouvons nous en féliciter
nous devons toutefois poursuivre nos
efforts
une ratification de l'accord fait qu'à
est naturellement une nécessité nous la
voterons d'après ce que je comprends
tous à une exception près il est tout à
la fois une étape est un levier pour
aboutir la disparition programmée des
angles morts fiscaux à l'échelle
internationale et afin que cesse cette
insupportable entrave à la justice
sociale
merci monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
ministre christy ricker vous m'avez
demandé la parole vous l'avez oui merci
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs voudraient faire et
remercier l'ensemble des orateurs pour
la qualité du débat et pour la relative
unanimité que je voit se dessiner en
cette fin de session parlementaire
effectivement ça peut nous changer un
peu mais non ce que j'ai envie de nous
dire collectivement c'est n'ayons pas
trop de regrets j'ai entendu des regrets
parce que les choses ont mis du temps à
se faire
c'est vrai j'ai entendu des regrets
parce que les choses ne sont pas
complètement achevé
c'est vrai
quelle oeuvre humaine d'ailleurs été
complètement achevé au sujet de
philosophie au bac la femme peut-être
mais ne boudons pas notre plaisir
on a l'occasion de saluer
l'aboutissement d'un processus qui
certes est dû au volontarisme d'abord
unilatérale des américains mais enfin
s'il y avait besoin de ça pourra faire
avancer les choses en europe
voilà c'est chose faite continuons à
travailler à progresser sur ces sujets
effectivement complexe j'ai entendu ce
qu'il faut faire encore en termes de
réciprocité on sait qu'il manque un
stand de dispositions pour que la
réciprocité soit complète il avait
d'ailleurs évoqué je crois un tribune
je sais aussi ce qu'il reste à faire
pour faire avancer le principe baisse au
niveau de l' ocde mais je crois que il
serait quand même stupide de ne pas
ratifier cette convention dans la mesure
où elles apportent indéniablement des
progrès de la connaissance dans
l'identification des comptes bancaires
et des contribuables qui permettront
certes dans un premier temps il faudra
encore nous faudra encore faire des
interrogations cas par cas mais on
espère que les choses vont se
généraliser l'exception nous ayant
quittés
je voudrais quand même lui répondre on
ne dit que singapour on nous dit qu'il
ya encore faim je comprends pas très
bien cette exception pas pardon de te le
dire en son absence mais je ne comprends
pas très bien parce qu'on nous dit on
serait en fait le tro bon élève par
rapport à d'autres qui n'auraient pas
qu'ils se seraient pas engagés dans la
démarche d'ailleurs je ne partage pas
complètement j'ai sous les yeux la liste
des états qui ont des soie signée soit
paraphé les
les accords fait qu'à ce soit sur le
modèle 1 soit sur le modèle 2 je vous en
ai pas la lecture mais il ya des noms
assez surprenant quand même là encore ce
n'est pas complètement abouti parfois ce
n'est que par a fait fondre à signer et
ratifier mais il ya jersey le
liechtenstein le luxembourg les îles
cayman la suisse bien entendu panama
singapour dont quand on dit qu'on serait
en avance et qu'on se réveille seul oui
on sera probablement de parmi les
premiers à avoir ratifié la convention
l'enfant ne sera pas les seuls donc chez
le juge
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre
l'exception beaucoup de choses ont été
dites ou évoqué une consultation presque
en direct qui a été fait me l'a même
goût les français de l'étranger si les
contribuables aux etats unis du fait de
sa résidence aux états unis et bien la
formation devrait être transmise dans le
champ de fat casse et c'est
l'application de la règle j'espère que
cette consultation gratuite vous aura
satisfait
et puis à propos de votre remarque sur
fico vie je vous signale quand même que
dans une vie antérieure pardon de le
redire deux fois en deux jours je crois
dans une vie antérieure j'ai déposé un
amendement
fico vie et créé par la loi de finances
dans la loi de finances de fin 2013
certes son application sera pas
immédiate passe quinze ans de travaux à
réaliser pour que ce soit opérationnel
mais fico vie c'était une de nos
demandes je crois assez générale est
créée voilà pardon de ne pas répondre
très précisément mme à cette heure
tardive cette heure tardive crois que il
faut laisser la place à mon collègue qui
a d'ailleurs eu un travail très
difficile cet après midi je crois
malheureusement et je pense que c'est
pour lui aussi difficile de revenir ici
après ce qu'il a dû accompagner durant
cet après midi je crois que quelqu'un
s'interrogeait sur les moyens mis à
disposition de l'administration pour
faire face aux exigences et aux
possibilités qui fa qui sont les nôtres
oui je veux rassurer sur ce point dont
d'ailleurs de renforcer les services
actuellement du spdr dont il est une des
questions plusieurs fois ces derniers
jours
donc je crois mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs vous serez effectivement les
premiers puisque l'assemblée nationale
je crois ne connaîtra pas ce plaisir
avant l'interruption
et donc je me réjouis que nous puissions
à une exception près que peu de mal à
comprendre
adopter ce texte même si on a conscience
du travail qui reste à faire
merci monsieur le ministre la discussion
générale est close nous passons donc à
la discussion de l'article unique et je
vais mettre revoir l'article unique
constituant l'ensemble du projet de loi
autorisant l'approbation de l'accord
entre le gouvernement de la république
française et le gouvernement des états
unis d'amérique en vue d'améliorer le
respect des obligations fiscales à
l'échelle internationale et de mettre en
oeuvre la loi relative au respect des
obligations fiscales concernant les
comptes étrangers dite loi fatca pas de
demande de prise de parole d'explication
votre jeu n'en voit pas donc je mets on
voit qui est pour et qui est contre qui
s'abstient un texte voté avec une belle
unanimité ce projet de loi est donc
adopté